hello guys I'm Ryan right I am Jerry
today we're gonna be reviewing 2016 the
way Shh okay so this movie there's
there's we're gonna try to cover this in
just a few minutes we don't want to you
don't want to give a single spoiler from
this film trailers really good at doing
that this is one of those movies or it's
like even if you spoil something it's
really bad I mean like don't but the
journey of watching it and experiencing
and going through all that is still
intact oh man totally totally cuz it's
not as much about the answer is what it
all feels like yeah this movie is really
defined on its tone its style I don't
know if it's one of the most eerie films
I've ever seen but it's definitely one
of the most eerie films I've seen in a
very long time like yeah it really like
gets under your skin like yeah it's
really creepy way I mean it's really
sparse and foreboding and and at times
very almost bleak you know like it's not
a fun that's not fun but it's definitely
engaging yeah and and and it does take
its time like it moves the way life
probably would have backed them like
it's not a fast paced movie or overly
like that yeah movie it moves forward
with this dread that's that's totally
heightened I mean first and foremost by
that music you know oh yeah that's the
score in this the score is [ __ ] nuts
it's great and boy does it add because
there are some shots like especially in
the beginning where that takes are going
on for a long time when I started asking
myself would I be scared right now if
the music wasn't playing but the music
is certainly making the scary selves are
enough though too because there's a lot
of long shots that hold on things and
you're sort of just left to go on this
journey with people you know and it's a
gripping tale because and that's why I
mean the word is tale like yeah it is it
I mean I think the subtitle at the
beginning it says something you know I
forget it's like a pure fairy tale or
the
something like that when it comes to the
cinematography yeah I mean obviously
from the trailers you were like it looks
[ __ ] beautiful still it's not too
artsy and too flashy to the point where
you're like it's just express my
expressive yes or because it's Revere
it's done beautiful to look at but not
an abstract you in a way that only pulls
you in that much further it's artistic
yet you feel like you're there yeah yeah
it feels that's what makes us so
creepies you feel like you're there
would the way that takes go on and and
the dialogue the writing is so authentic
like I wasn't part of that time period
so I can't really claim authenticity but
there is its own type of style and time
period to the dialogue it doesn't feel
Hollywood modernize at all well
everything about this movie kind of
feels like it's inspired by the time
it's from because the way it's shot and
edited like there aren't a lot of moving
shots and there are a lot of very long
takes it's very sparse in the way that
it assembles itself there's not a lot of
quick cutting yeah the dialogue I mean
they're pretty upfront about like most
of the dialogue is taken from Diaries
and accountants and things like that so
these are words that were a lot of them
anyway we're words that were either said
or written by people who live during
this time period you know they tell how
to research and it's it's one of those
great horror movies that really is about
the characters this is strongly about
the characters their interactions
consequence it like how everything
affects the more this movie goes the
more the characters are affected oh yeah
it's about life at this time it's what
living is light at this time because
like you know it shows you a lot of
their day in and day out activity and
how they're feeling like I said it's not
it's not a super Pilate movie no no but
it does show you what life is life and
it forces you to kind of walk through
that they're on the edge of a plantation
I think yeah it's just as old or as
little cornfield however it still feels
kind of contained because of the time
period it's in like they can't travel
they're not surrounded by anyone else
but trees yeah like the nearest town is
like a days horse ride exactly there and
they have one horse one horse a small
corn of you know their house does
any windows because they don't any glass
it's a very you know Spartan life yeah
and like that and there's so much God
like what's really cool about this film
is it's much more of a psychological
terror film than it is like which
haunting actually there's a lot of that
there but it's not primarily that and
I'm pretty sure when you walk away from
the film you will be walking away
thinking about all the psychological
turmoil because rather than a
traditional movie especially in a modern
day time where something creepy is
happening the characters look stupid
everything feels like yeah I get why
this person's perceiving it this way I
get why that one's perceiving it this
way like it always makes sense top it
off a great dialogue and awesome awesome
performances from the whole cast from
the father the mother the daughter the
son even the little kids the twins you
know like they were all everybody like
fantastic and the thing is you know this
movie kind of shines a light through the
the doubt cracks and everybody because
that's really what it's not like a witch
movie like AHA spells uncle [ __ ] like
it's about what the idea of witchcraft
and Satan does to these P at the
beginning of America well yeah exactly
we're all you have is kind of your word
and your faith you know people are
trying to grow up and it's super
repressive and like this the nation isms
and how big religion played to i felt
like is this gonna be one of those
movies where witchcraft starts happening
and they're just throwing Bible verses
at witches all the time it's not that
movie at all that's one thing I greatly
respect any time I thought this film was
gonna be predictable or cliche it never
did it yeah it always gave something
different cuz it uses witches in
witchcraft the way you would if that was
just like kind of an idea in life you
know for them because you know you
believe so heavily in a very literal
version of God and Satan so like witches
are probably a thing that's been
whispered about in town that and and the
movie treated it that way it's not like
the strange thing happens at the
beginning and everyone's like it's
witches you know it takes a while to get
to these conclusions and it doesn't get
to them like you said in a cliche way
manages to feel very dark and violent
when you look back on it you're like
it's not that gory you know like I don't
think there's like Gore but there's some
violent [ __ ] like yeah I mean there's
violence they know when to cut from
things they know when to leave you with
the impact and not the image you know
I'm looking back on it every character
goes through it all right yeah because
every character has something up yeah
you know like we meet the dad the first
scene in the movie is basically and
being like none of you were as faithful
as I am like you're all you know
hypocrites and [ __ ] we're gonna leave
town everything falls on top of the dad
is the leadership and then you're
starting to see when like looks like
you've been charged and questioned and
yeah yeah it's like you've got the son
who's like starting to grow up and he's
starting to take on responsibilities and
you've got the older daughter who's
dealing with trying to become a woman
when that's clearly not encouraged by
the system they live in and in certain
ways not that this is like the main
metaphor of the movie but there's almost
like the which is kind of like coming
into your own as a woman you don't
understand that at this point in time
and it's like her mother is you know
very austere and very straightforward
but even she harbors some resentment
towards you know the dad and that keeps
coming up in little ways the two twins
are just [ __ ] around all the time
yeah so everyone's got a very clear you
know portrait last thing I want to say
before I wrap up this review this is one
of those films that it sucks because
it's getting released too early in the
year to the point where it's not gonna
get recognized by things such as Oscar
consideration or whatever and when
there's so much in this ROM like this is
Oscar worthy performances cinematography
even the writing this is one of those
horror movies that's this grand film
it's way more than just a horror flick
it's a film well it's it's very literary
like it reminded me sort of and this is
probably not a spot-on reference but it
almost reminded me of like Nathaniel
Hawthorne it almost reminded me of parts
of Young Goodman Brown which is like a
story near the time you know it's got a
very literary quality in it and it's
very austere that way this is another
one where it's like it's a tremendous
horror movie but it's also just like a
really well made damn film regardless of
that I mean you're not gonna walk out
like no it's great oh yeah
it's done I was like shake some [ __ ] off
you're gonna feel dark and strange and
and and all sort of thing but it's
imperative it's very effective yeah yeah
it'd still be forward it's deliberately
paced it's not a fast me it's a very
slow burn you're you're watching life
funders yes sir and the perfect word for
that yes love burning the pork gives you
just enough every few minutes it
develops very naturally so um rating
time since you people can't understand
YouTube reviews without ratings ah dude
I give it like a hundred Jerry's maybe
like a hundred 6j go with that yeah both
my ratings are gonna become Jerry's I
just want to give him points that way no
one knows like what the type of final
point is yeah give it 20,000 points yeah
start giving things points the way like
whose line doesn't matter that's a big
number I guess that's a good anyway
subscribe with this Channel become a
rejectable you're worth your time you
got [ __ ] on this channel reasons to
Jerry playlists we turn all the vids
Jerry's and Inc a stuff podcast hosted
by Jerry follow me on vine Instagram and
Twitter follow Jerry on Twitter
Instagram and Vine way what do you use I
use I gotta use vine more but Instagram
Twitter all that jazz I have a vine it's
just Jerry where youtubers expose
themselves already on YouTube and expose
themselves even more on other social
media no such thing is a personal life
no not ever
zero times